[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
journal de l'afrique sur france 24 à la
une ce soir en ethiopie de nouveaux
bombardements ont touché mais quelle est
la capitale de la région rebelle du
tigre et les autorités locales rendu
doit l'armée éthiopienne de quoi voir
s'éloigner les minces espoirs d'une paix
négociée
au kenya après une élection très serrée
début août et plusieurs semaines de
controverse william ruto a prêté serment
ce mardi devant soixante mille personnes
prend la tête d'un pays profondément
divisé nous serons anaérobie retrouver
bastien renouer notre correspondant et
puis en côte d'ivoire un pionnier de la
tec a créé le premier smartphone à
commande entièrement vocal avec un accès
dans seize langues locales et le succès
vous le verrez tous rendez vous pour cet
outil destiné aux utilisateurs qui ne
savent ni lire ni écrire reportage à
suivre
les autorités de la région rebelle du
tigre et accuse donc l'armée éthiopienne
d'avoir mené une nouvelle frappe sur
mais quelle est leur capitale c'est la
troisième fois que la ville est ciblé
depuis la reprise des hostilités fin
août ce nouveau bombardement intervient
deux jours après une proposition de
reprise de dialogue de la part des
autorités tigréenne sous l'égide de
l'union africaine caroline lamboley
l'université de mekele serait l'une des
cibles de l'attaqué survenue mardi matin
aussi visé les locaux d'une chaîne de
télévision les rebelles du tigre et
évoque des lourds dégâts humains et
matériels
le bilan est toujours incertain selon un
responsable au sein du principal hôpital
de la région
une frappe de drone est survenu tôt ce
matin à mekele un blessé est arrivé à
l'hôpital daider le nombre total des
victimes n'est pas encore connu
mais qu'elle est et la capitale des
rebelles du tigré région en guerre
depuis fin 2020 le conflit éclate
lorsque le gouvernement envoie l'armée
fédérale au tigré pour déloger les
autorités dissidente de la région accusé
d'avoir attaqué deux bases de l'armée
fédérale éthiopienne
un porte parole du front de libération
du peuple du tigré souligne que cette
attaque de mardi intervient alors que
les rebelles venaient d'ouvrir la porte
à un nouveau cessez le feu
l'attaqué survient après que le
gouvernement du tigre et a mis en place
une équipe de négociation et exprimé sa
volonté pour des pourparlers de paix
depuis fin août les combats ont repris
dans cette région du nord de l'ethiopie
après une trêve qui n'aura duré que cinq
mois les deux camps se rejettent la
responsabilité de la reprise des combats
direction le kenya voisin william ruto
est devenu aujourd'hui le cinquième
président du pays il a officiellement
prêté serment tout à l'heure devant des
milliers de personnes la fin de semaine
de controverses après une élection très
serrée est contestée par son rival raila
odinga elle sa victoire avait été
finalement invalidée souvenez vous par
la cour suprême c'était la semaine
dernière moto ainsi la tête d'un pays
profondément divisé anaérobie on
retrouve bastien renouer notre
correspondant
certains soutiens de william couteaux
sont arrivés dès 4 heures du matin pour
s'assurer qu'ils auraient une place au
sein du stade maïdo cassara ni la plus
grande enceinte sportive du kenya le
président william ou toya prêté serment
ce mardi matin il y avait de très
nombreux invités des vip des diplomates
ou encore tous les chefs d'état de la
communauté d'afrique de l'est ainsi que
d'autres chefs d'état et premiers
ministres d'afrique et puis 60000
soutien de william bhutto qui avait fait
le déplacement pour voir leur président
prêté serment
je vous propose d'écouter certains
d'entre eux mêmes quoi mourir c'était
important pour moi de venir de voir auto
en vrai je crois beaucoup en lui je
pourrais aussi raconter aux gens de mon
village que j'ai vu hors auto prêté
serment et que je suis venu à naïrobi
j'ai voté pour william ruto j'attendais
qu'on annonce sa victoire quand j'ai vu
qu'il devait faire face à la justice a
brisé le coeur alors j'ai voulu voir de
mes yeux ce qui allait se passer durant
sa prestation de serment
william ruto a reçu les attributs du
pouvoir des mains du son prédécesseur
uhuru kenyatta qui a d'ailleurs été
chaleureusement applaudi par le stade en
dépit des tensions entre les deux hommes
au cours des derniers mois william ruto
a ensuite pris la parole il a remercié
durant un très court discours sa famille
ses amis ainsi que dieu on sait que
c'est un fervent croyant et il a été
applaudi chaleureusement par les 60000
personnes présentes dans le stade
soixante mille personnes qui tout comme
le reste du pays vont scruter avec
attention williams ou tôt au cours des
prochains mois il ya une grave crise
économique dans le pays et tout le monde
attend de voir quelles solutions le
nouveau président va pouvoir apporter
au sénégal moins de deux mois après des
élections législatives extrêmement serré
les parlementaires ont fait leur rentrée
rentrée sous tensions et marquée par une
série d'incidents le président macky
sall dont la coalition a obtenu une
majorité de justesse a tout de même
réussi à faire élire son candidat à la
présidence de l'assemblée amadou ousmane
diop 57 ans élu au cours d'un vote
boycotté par l'opposition
les précisions depuis dakar d'elimane
il aura fallu près de dix heures de
débats houleux d'empoignades et même
l'intervention de dizaines de gendarmes
pour procéder à l'élection du président
de l'assemblée nationale du sénégal dans
une rentrée parlementaire attendues les
députés de l'opposition n'étaient pas
d'accord sur le texte de l'assemblée
nationale notamment sur la présence de
ministres toujours en fonction qui ont
été élus députés lors des dernières
législatives pour ses ministres ne
devait pas être présent lors de cette
rentrée parlementaire à les deux
coalitions de l'opposition us can be
well au sénégal ont finalement boycotté
le vote du président de l'assemblée
nationale au moment où les députés de la
coalition au pouvoir gbagbo qui as
cannes ont procédé à l'élection d'un
amour omar diop désormais nouveau
président de l'assemblée nationale cette
ambiance électrique dans laquelle s'est
déroulée cette rentrée parlementaire
était un peu prévisible au vu de la
composition inédite de l'assemblée
nationale du sénégal pour la première
fois dans l'histoire du pays
l'opposition a un poids à parlementaire
quasi équivalent à celui du pouvoir au
terme des élections législatives du 31
juillet à les députés se réclamant de
l'opposition étaient au nombre de 82
contre 83 alors pour le pouvoir le mano
à mano devrait se poursuivre dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois avec le vote du budget des
différents ministères et tout cela en
moins de 18 mois de la prochaine
présidentielle en 2024 ils avaient été
arrêtés après les manifestations fin
juillet contre la junte guinéenne trois
leaders du fn décès le front national
pour la défense de la constitution sont
toujours en prison en attente d'un
jugement
leur état de santé et leurs conditions
d'incarcération
préoccupe leurs avocats écouté il était
au micro de malik diakité au jour
d'aujourd'hui il n'y a aucun élément
sérieux j'ai dit et j'insiste là dessus
aucun élément sérieux compte nos clients
et il continue à séjourner dans la
maison d'arrêt de conakry
donc au cela est incompréhensible c'est
inacceptable parce que nous nous
estimons et nous considérons que c'est
un dossier totalement vide il ne sait
même inexistant parce qu'il n'a rien
d'un jeu dossier au gabon après six ans
de détention l'ancien député bertrand
zibi à berrer a été remis en liberté la
nuit dernière il avait été interpellé en
août 2016 durant la crise post
électorale puis condamné pour violences
voies de feuilles détention illégale
d'armes à feu il a toujours clamé son
innocence à libreville les précisions 10
mélo bien pesé
je sors de la prison centrale de
libreville sans un sentiment de haine
encore moins de rancune tout au
contraire avec beaucoup d'amour telles
sont les premières déclarations de
bertrand ebe abreu l'ex pensionnaire de
la prison centrale de libreville
souhaite vite tourner la page de cette
détention et jure pleinement de sa
liberté l'ancien élu du parti au pouvoir
le pdg le parti démocratique gabonais
passé dans l'opposition aux côtés de
jean ping en 2016 il reste visiblement
combatif et fidèle à ses convictions je
vous propose de l'écouter suivi de la
réaction de charles henry g l'un de ses
avocats le pdg j'ai été le pdg l'équité
au su et au vu de tout le monde
j'ai intégré la coalition de
l'opposition qui a soutenu le candidat
jean ping pour le moment j'observe et
bertrand est d'abord rendre à son destin
en main il ya un temps pour tout et un
temps pour la joie c'est le temps de la
joie est pure à un autre temps pour les
grandes décisions aujourd'hui nous
devons fêter la sortie de bertrand zibi
nous devons nous réjouir de ce qu'ils
soient en bonne santé
incarcéré puis condamné pour violences
voies de fait et détention illégale
d'armes à fleurs il a intégralement
purger sa peine de six ans pour rappel
bertrand remy à boro et son conseil ont
toujours clamé son innocence dans les
incidents qui ont suivi la rélection
d'ali bongo ondimba à l'issue de la
présidentielle de 2016 au gabon et enfin
en côte d'ivoire un smartphone un peu
particuliers rencontrent en ce moment un
important succès à commande entièrement
vocale il permet un accès dans seize
langues locales ce téléphone peut ainsi
être utilisé par tous ceux qui ne savent
ni lire ni écrire regardez ce reportage
signé ange nommé niaux et damien koffi
il s'appelle open un téléphone qui parle
plusieurs langues africaines seuls 11
finalement sans orage dans la langue
baoulé
c'étaient les foules portable a été
conçu pour faciliter son usage aux
personnes qui ne savent ni lire ni
écrire sur les parents c'est vraiment
important
parce qu'il connaît que le nom auquel
ils ont ici keller écrit par énoncer des
messages importants que vos parents sont
buzet d'aller voir un petit frère ou
bien encore pour les demandes et
la madeleine joue peur clients et
revendeuse fait partie de ces personnes
depuis qu'elle utilise le téléphone open
elle n'a jamais eu de difficulté conso
or un set face à l'as efforts faits
cités dans ce qui est appelé mes parents
et peut parler en français ça iphone
amorçable dépendent beaucoup d'élan donc
ça me plaît beaucoup
la fabrication du téléphone se fait à
grand bassam à l'est d'abidjan alain
capo chichi le concepteur est d'origine
béninoise il est le premier entrepreneur
à avoir installé une usine d'assemblage
d'ordinateurs en afrique de l'ouest pour
son nouveau téléphone il voit déjà grand
au delà de fait mais celle de marielle
concussion donc pousser une langue
africaine nous avons été très heureux
qu'on a eu près de 2000 locuteur qui ne
sont enregistré avec lesquels nous
travaillons aujourd'hui pour être
capables nous permettra ce que les gens
ne nous dit rien des gens qui sont en
afrique du sud qui sont kenya au
zimbabwe la zambie que c'est dans la
puce aussi utiliser leur téléphone
la super content j'allais dire avec leur
langue l'idée plan d'action de façon
automatisée le téléphone open est
disponible sur le marché ivoirien à un
prix qui varie entre 30000 et 60 mille
francs cfa soit l'équivalent d'une somme
comprise entre 45 et 91 euros sa
commercialisation se fait déjà au bénin
au burkina faso et en rdc
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal de
l'afrique merci beaucoup de l'avoir
suivi rester avec nous sur france24
l'information continue
[Musique]
alors que la france est en perte
d'influencé en centrafrique les
mercenaires russes de la société wagner
occupe le devant de la scène
[Musique]
il sera là pour protéger statuer
production de films courts us accompagne
cette présence paramilitaires dans le
cadre d'une propagande agressive qui
vise à masquer les massacres et viols
dont sont accusées ces mercenaires mais
la prise de contrôle des ressources
minières et l'invasion russe en ukraine
font douter de plus en plus de centres
africains les russes sont venus attaquer
et le crème et c'est la même chose
sans appliquer
reporter le dock centrafrique l'emprise
russe à voir sur france 24 et france 24
points comme
[Musique]
vous allez voir et écouter le temps
qu'il fait avec écouter voir écouter
voir optique audition mutualiste